what good morning Millennials welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday it
feels like a Monday also like it's what
a week it's a confusing day but it's
Thursday congratulations you made it to
the latter half of the week acknowledge
that be proud of yourself pat yourself
on the back I know I am because I'm here
I'm in New York and it's it's back to
the good old days it's OG recipe
original recipe Jackson Claude New York
Studio pink chairs Bryce is here
stress is not here and the stress is not
here no I said Bryce yes yes yes but
it's not like a Bryce and strike Affair
I feel like Bryce needed his own show
like he has had a hard time you know
yesterday it was all good and fun his
auntie was staying at his house next
thing he knows I'm gone yeah and it's
been hard for Bryce to adjust to and so
we needed a special moment Brew was in
New York and he's thriving here speaking
of hard yesterday I traveled with you
and Harry for the first time I've never
traveled with a baby I don't think so
we've traveled once as a family with
Kayla but there was like eight adults to
one kid it didn't seem like such a big
deal
um this time it was me you and Ben Theo
and roldini and
the way I'm not okay and I did again
five percent like literally was just
like doing the fun stuff I'm not okay
it's back breaking
back breaking and then like when we got
you you got to your your room and you
hours later we got on the phone like
you're editing the redheads I'm like wow
she really does it all like
passion projects motherhood it's it's
admirable truly thank you so much well
it's exciting to be here and you just
have the adrenaline it's crazy like the
energy that you muster when it's
required when it's required no that's
like life yeah
um but you're back in New York and isn't
it like a fabulous time in New York oh
my God it's a fabulous time to be in New
York Bryce and I were walking down the
street and I don't think you've ever
seen two more fabulous people it's just
gorgeous weather feeling ourselves
feeling our look like feeling this city
it's um like holiday season like it's
starting this energy that I'm putting
forth like I know I'm gonna get punched
in the face on the wall call yeah no you
deserve it too like if someone's gonna
spit in your mouth shoved and brought
back down to earth it's literally like
that scene in 30 Rock where everything
couldn't be going for Liz better for Liz
Lemon she's running through the streets
and a homeless man spits in her mouth
yeah that's you that's gonna be me and
Bryce but no it's glorious to be here on
such a week as this we are working
that's you're here because we have an
event we are like literally like a vent
girls night we have a holiday party and
then it's your b day it was his 30th
birthday so I decided to make a weekend
out of it and I'm really glad that I did
I was gonna do a weekend in Florida but
things weren't panning out and then this
work thing came up and I was like what
if we just went to New York and Harry's
just like in New York yeah he's
literally Eloise he loves New York he's
literally Baby's Day Out I've been
saying that Harry looks like the baby
from Baby's Day Out and now that he's in
New York like I know while you're out
working he's at the zoo I need to go
watch that movie again I watched it
recently because they weirdly have it on
like Delta or United and when I tell it
first of all Cynthia Nixon is in it
which is just bizarre
um it is such a sweet movie like you
will love it even though like at its
core it's like a thriller like the baby
gets kidnapped right and baby's on his
own right so at its core like it
probably if you're a mom like will
actually give you anxiety of course but
like the baby was never really in any
danger right like the people who
kidnapped him were like completely inept
and he was kidnapped for all of four
seconds before being home alone like
he's technically Under Siege no it's so
we're enjoying this fun family film yeah
like it's technically an episode of Law
and Order yeah but he's okay he's
hostage in his own home no that's so so
true and like
baby's dad is even more howling because
it's like a toddler like at least Kevin
McAllister like you know had the brain
and the mobility to entrap the the
kidnappers yes but this baby does not
have said abilities no he does not also
you mentioned the redheads which I just
want to thank you for of course the
episode is not up yet um because I was
editing last night and then it got too
late so it's almost done being edited
and it will be up today as soon as the
toast is over
um just things got things got crazy no
like the Moguls would be kind of like
out moggled ourselves because like the
redhead too close to the sun because the
redheads is like slightly delayed our
patreon our first patreon Vlog of the
month went up last night it had to be
taken down and re-edited so like that
one's gonna be up today like we truly
have outmodeled ourselves yeah we were
going too fast maybe we should start a
new segment at Mogul yourselves
gmail.com
um so we've got a fabulous show it's
Thursday we've got some measly stories
no TV recap because I couldn't watch any
TV last night and like I'm genuinely
done with the Real Housewives of Salt
Lake City like it's not even on my plate
anymore because this is not my plate
genuinely done except I saw a headline
today that I thought was interesting
like I guess on last night's episode
Whitney Rose revealed that her husband
was fired from his job because of that
scene where they're like painting body
painting in the bedroom you know the
scene I mean yeah I mean yeah what does
he do
I don't know I didn't click it I just
saw the headline I do always find stuff
like that interesting when there's like
ramifications for a Housewives family
like sometimes our kids are asked to
like go to a different school
um their husbands lose their jobs like
Louie from Jersey recently like was
asked to leave his company that he
started which like made no sense
um so I do always find that really
interesting that's sad yeah but at the
end of the day like you get into a
position when you're on one of these
shows like sometimes like the wife
starts making more money
than the man and I feel like in a lot of
the situations before like the wives
weren't working yeah and I mean I have
to watch the episode but also when you
think about like Wild Rose and like
everything they invested into it and now
it's like even more pressure oh yikes if
he doesn't have that job maybe he got a
different job yikes yeah oh okay that is
interesting
um
and so are we you know we're like two
beautiful girls with a beautiful podcast
and you're welcome for that you really
are
so I guess without further Ado we could
Jump Right In I guess like we have
nothing really else to talk about we
were just like busy all day yesterday
today was a travel day everybody saw us
I can't believe we did the toast
yesterday like did as much and regular
time regular episode like did everything
that we did in the last 24 hours no when
I got into bed last night I'm like Ben I
cannot believe I did the toast today
like it was the same day four different
days there was something oh um there was
something that happened like two days
ago at yesterday and I was talking about
it I was like well yesterday this
happened I was like was that yesterday
or was that last week oh yeah you know
totally it was crazy
um so I'm happy for you like being here
it feels like old times just like you
know us back in studio just regular
girls New York City podcasters yeah it's
nice it is nice we'll have to do some
New York City Tings after this Empire
State Building Morgan Library the Morgan
ladders the Morgan ladders are actually
at the market they should be it's
Morgan's library but Sonia was like in
Pennsylvania when she said that probably
those letters but I'm sure Morgan has
many ladders and I think the Hub of
Morgan paraphernalia would be at the
Morgan Library do you think Sonia Morgan
has ever been to the Morgan Library yes
perhaps when she was a Morgan no I meant
like recently I don't know how the
library feels about Sonia Morgan today
yeah no that's it's a very serious
Library yeah and it's the library behind
the book The personal a librarian so
it's a really great read do you know
that dumois said that she hears like
Beverly Hills housewives is going on the
same type of Hiatus that New York
Housewives is going on like they're
doing some sort of restructure I heard
that I don't believe that I don't
believe that that just makes sense to me
no that would make no sense I feel like
Beverly Hills this season was just as
good as any other season I feel like
maybe with Beverly Hills they film the
ring in the reunion errors and then they
start filming again a week later maybe
that's not happening this year right but
they're not gonna go the route of New
York I don't think I mean that would
literally make no sense like New York
wasn't even good enough to have a
reunion and Beverly Hills had a
three-part Reunion yeah no it doesn't
make any sense but I do think maybe
they're taking like a minute to figure
out the Kathy Lisa stuff because they
definitely want Kathy back Kathy won't
return if Lisa's there so maybe that's
what they're working out perhaps or
they're just taking a longer break than
normal maybe the women are a little
burnt out there was also a rumor that
Cynthia Bailey um and someone else I
forget who uh
Heather Dubrow no I saw Cynthia Bailey
and someone and we're talking about yes
but then there was also um because we
reported that they sold their house for
like a record the dubros
um a record amount and that they bought
a penthouse in LA and like she's perhaps
gonna be on Beverly Hills housewives got
it and honestly I don't see it no she's
like yes she's you know the it's easy to
be the most glamorous woman in Orange
County I don't think she would cut it
honestly
and her personality I don't think would
mix well yeah because the thing about
the Beverly Hills housewives is like
yeah they're all rich and fantasy but
like they throw down too and like they
get messy and like one thing about
Heather like she's a great house like
but she never got messy and like you
need a little bit of that yeah to
survive so those were just some things
people were saying on the internet which
is meaningless a conversation we were
literally just having right before this
we were yeah just goes to show you
really need to be careful but careful
about what you consume on the internet
no and it's like it's just the way
things people say things with such
Authority it's like why wouldn't you
just assume they know what they're
talking about right right and then like
yeah whatever
um
okay should we dive in let's dive in to
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
of your toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
zocadoc a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are available when
you need them on ZocDoc you can find
every specialist Under the Sun whether
you're trying to straighten your teeth
fix an achy back get that mold checked
out or removed ZocDoc has you covered so
zocdoc's mobile app is as easy as
ordering a ride to a restaurant getting
delivery to your house you just search
find and book doctors with a few Taps it
can be really hard to find a doctor one
if you like move to a new area it's like
hard to find a good recommendation then
one who takes your insurance then one
who's in a good location like near your
work or your house so ZocDoc is really
kind of revitalized the the doctor
industry if I do say so myself
you can find and review local doctors
read verified patient reviews from real
people who have made real appointments
and when you walk into that doctor's
office you're all set to see someone in
your network who gets you go to
zocdoc.com find the right doctor that is
right for you and book an appointment in
person or remotely that works for your
schedule every month millions of people
use ZocDoc we are two of them it is our
go-to whenever we need to find and book
a quality doctor obviously you just
moved so zoctac has been huge for you
when I travel for work I'm like so
susceptible to like toothaches rashes
like I'm always getting mysterious
illnesses when I travel and if I'm on
tour and I have a day off like I will go
to ZocDoc and try and find a doctor who
can take me who's on my insurance who
can take me that day and it's been
actually really really helpful for me
speaking of toothache coincidence I do
and it's making me realize I need to get
on talk talk and find the dentist oh do
not have a new dentist yet in Florida
yeah and you can you can tell you could
bet your ass you're going to Zach don't
I need to go slush toast I think I need
to go to zoc talk to find a dentist who
can give me veneers I'm ready for my big
teeth I'm ready for my big teeth era I'm
ready for that for you too to mock you
endlessly go to zocdoc.com toast
download this download the ZocDoc app
for free then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com toast zuckduck.com toast it's
wickedly talented the wickedly talented
doctors.com the wickedly talented
zucktuck.com toast gorgeous you're
welcome our first story it's really sexy
news you guys oh my God so weird Olivia
just texted me at the dentist wish me
luck she has to get a tooth pulled oh
goodness best wishes girly go
if you're not happy with how he does
right right if you have any complaints
toast don't forget about that did I you
didn't when you just said that how
embarrassing yeah our first story is
really sexy news so like if there's kids
around like NSFW you might want to cover
their ears cover Bryce's ears oh my
angel Ina Garten's husband Jeffrey
accidentally sent an NSFW text to her
publicist I really like that little
um jingle you put on Jeffrey there's no
other way to say it you have to say it
like Aina would Jeffrey's coming home
from Yale I think I'll make a roast
chicken for Jeffrey
I know we're called on the Drew
Barrymore Show episode airing next
Monday that the economist wow the What
Jeffrey is an economist but he was a
professor of the economy
um well if I'm a gym teacher am I a
professional athlete like no you would
be a um
you would we could say athlete I
literally would love to be a gym teacher
like I cannot lie you might have been an
economist first term Professor that's
how things work like that's like you
know uh
a NBA player then becoming like the
coach of the kids basketball Steve Nash
not or of the NBA
if you went from the NBA to his kids
basketball team like that's a step down
he's still a coach ain't it good to be
the coach now I'm confusing myself you
told me that Inside Amy Schumer is
coming back yes I'm like really excited
Paramount or peacock one of the peas it
is coming back I recently you like made
me doubt myself because I thought I saw
it I thought Dana sent it to me and then
I told you he was coming back you're
like no it's not and I'm like yeah no
maybe it was like a spoof or something
and then I saw it again that that it is
coming back to one of the streamers so I
never even watched it when it was on I
wasn't like a fan of TV show whatever
but I became obsessed you showed me I
mean it good to be the coach her spoof
on Friday Night Lights and then I went
down like a rabbit hole and watched like
all the sketches and I'm genuinely
excited for it I hope it's good yeah I
hope it's good I really hope it's
there's a big chance that it's not like
and that it's just
miserable and like political which is
horny he's like so and like predictable
yeah kind of like SNL honestly yeah yeah
no I hope like she's like there was also
a sketch where it's like a bunch of
women meet up in the park and like they
run into each other and they're like oh
man I love your sweater it's like how
women can't take a compliment yeah it's
like a new woman keeps coming up it's
like oh my God I love your sweater
thanks I found it in the dumpster did
you get your haircut yeah literally like
I burnt all my hair off like it was so
um like on the nose of what it's like to
be a woman and I hope she keeps that
like energy was so relatable yeah and I
hope that she says something new yes you
know yeah not just like recycling the
jokes that everyone says now yes yeah
sorry like total tangent from Aina total
tangent but apparently Jeffrey The
Economist texted I understand
publicist saying you're gonna be
delicious tonight the TV cook shared
that her publicist and longtime friends
hilarious response was I don't think
this was meant for me when Drew asked
whether Aina uh whether her publicist
turned right red the Food Network
personality replied I didn't see it but
I am mad imagine so I mean not if you
had asked me like what kind of sex does
Jeffrey send that's what I would have
chosen he's nothing if not predictable
he's on brand I just want to say like
maybe it's me being like a conspiracy
theorist but I feel like Jeffrey and the
publicist are having some sort of an
affair and like this is aina's way of
getting ahead of it like going doing
press talking about sext Jeffries
Jeffrey sends like that's not aina's
Vibe when I first saw the headline I
thought the same thing like Jeffrey was
caught sending a sexy text to the
publicist like what is Jeffrey up to but
given the content of the text it was
meant for a chef that's true he might
have said something about like oh you're
gonna be so on public display tonight if
it was for a publicist you know I can't
wait to relate to those public titties I
can't wait to release your presses it's
like
oh no I can't wait to press my release
into you that's what I would say that
sounds like something from one of your a
hundred percent they're always calling
it a release in like those porn books
yeah
um or his manhood his sex
that's what they say I could feel his
sex yeah that's what they say
um I mean I could go on like for for
women they always call it a slit which
is like really like if it's a more
literary a bundle of nerves
that's what they say sometimes too
pretty good no you have to get creative
you can always say like [ __ ] so many
times you know yeah no that's why it's
crazy when they're just like big old
penis they never say actual anatomical
that's why it happened One Summer was so
jarring yes because they like I think he
was like calling it her [ __ ] like it
was wild for me It Happened One supper
was so jarring because you recommended
it to me oh yes but I I did recommend it
by saying like this is the spiciest book
I've ever read but I think what made it
so spicy was like their dirty talk was
like dirty no no I mean I've read books
where they literally say
[ __ ]
that's weird because at this point it's
a slur I kind of it's not a vagina no
it's literally a slur and that's like
what are you reading Game of Thrones
literally like they only use that in
medieval times yeah when the word meant
what it meant vagina yeah yeah so I mean
I could start a list of like Words
euphemisms but um I guess we could get
back to Ina and Jeffrey we can get back
to Ina and Jeffrey so this is just like
a funny moment from America's
Sweethearts really you know like not
them being relatable again you know
again also this article like just was
trying to find stuff to talk about Aina
and make it longer so I have to keep
scrolling but there is an Aina fun fact
that I'm obsessed with have you heard
about her engagement chicken yes
um
Emily Blunt made it for John Krasinski
really Aina has this chicken that she
that people say like if you make it for
your boyfriend like he will love it so
much he'll want to propose to you
because it's like amazing Homemaker by
the way and Meghan Markle made it for
Prince Harry okay by the way we've also
heard that story about Grammy and pop
like our grandparents like our
grandfather fell in love with our
grandma when he came over and she was
like bent over the oven pulling out a
big roast chicken from the oven it was a
brisket uh her brisket was fire but
recipes
um there's something yes there's
something to that whole notion like Anna
didn't invent that but yes yeah but like
apparently she has like an amazing
recipe that it's her famous roast
chicken look it up I should make it I
love roast chicken look how gorgeous it
looks I should make it too that actually
is like exactly what I want for dinner
tonight yeah but like oh I have to cook
it do you want your dinner now the way
you know what's so funny I was singing
about this last night because we had a
conversation about how certain random
movie
line lines like stick with certain
family members and I think a lot of
people I saw a lot of like comments and
people like were making tick tocks about
how like they really related to that
sentiment where it's like random obscure
movie lines that like your family for
some reason like really always says oh
that's a great Tick Tock Trend where
people really doing that yes and
everyone do that clip that segment and
then talk about the line so last night
me and Ben were talking and we like said
something and I realized it was one of
those things it is the most obscure
reference it's from an episode of my 600
pound life
where this guy he gets he's obviously
600 pounds in the footrest yes and so he
ends up getting married
um to this woman who has a daughter and
he literally turns this his new
stepdaughter like into a sermon like her
full-time job is like fetching things
for him so when in the beginning of the
episode we're like trying to get you
know context on how he lives his life
he's like quick way go on and fetch me
my foot rest and for some reason me and
Ben cannot stop saying it literally
because the joke is that like Ben is
and you need it first and I'm always
like Ben will you fetch me to Diet Coke
so like last night I had one of those
moments where I was like wow that is
such a niche random reference yes that
is also what's more crazy about us is
like so many of our references our
self-references like me from your
special yes obviously I want my dinner
now no that's what started this whole
conversation because when I was staying
at your house for literally two weeks
um every time we mentioned dinner I was
like both of us I want my dinner now
and like if you don't know what that's
from like gotta grab get a grip watch
the toast um you know it's another
really Niche reference but I feel like
maybe other people's family has it too I
have it with like my friends from high
school from Spanglish yes because you
have it with your friends from high
school and my college friends have it
with their family separately and like
one time you guys were talking someone
said it I'm like we were like shopping
and someone was like just try it on and
I was like did you just speak English
and by the way I actually recently
watched Spanglish and it is like such a
good movie I should I don't know that
I've ever watched it in full because
like with an appreciation for it you
know what I mean I feel like I've only
seen it here and there I actually think
you would love it I gotta add it to my
list yeah the movie list oh you know
what that actually just reminded me a
family movie for the holidays everyone
when you're done watching crawdads it is
I wanted to get um
you know like those kids toys that were
like little clipboards and like you
would like have like a little pen
attached and like I think we should
start writing down our list because I
wanted like a cute clipboard if you
could just write that down I want to get
one on Amazon okay so cross I'm making I
have a list of movies that like we're
obsessed with right this is gonna be
family movies list Spanish crawdads
crawdads um family movies murder on the
Orient holidays are coming up so you
need to start getting a list of
movies together that like most people in
your family different ages and interests
would like and that's not awkward and
like sexy yes also uh any Agatha
Christie we watch death on the Nile
which wasn't amazing it was fun but it
was fine it was fine
um and then we have like our favorite
movie segment and I only have three
what's your number Tad Hamilton so good
bad teacher so good I feel like we can
we can expand on that now that we know
that the list is here we'll keep adding
to it but also things another list
things I plan on doing sometime before I
pass away making this chicken
yes me too no and if you have like a
man's coming over like make the chicken
no and if you're like trying to get
engaged like you know you're this is the
guy for you make the chicken but don't
make it if you don't know if he's the
guy for you because then you'll be stuck
with him also don't make it like you're
so obsessed with you if you're like a
bad cook like no but I think that's like
the point of it it's like idiot proof I
think both chickens are like very easy
to make you put it all in a pan and then
you just put it in the oven for the
amount of time that Aina says it's
literally called the engagement roast
chicken on her website it's at
foodnetwork.com
and it looks pretty doable I've never
made a whole chicken Olivia makes it
good yeah I feel like once I do it once
I'll get comfortable yes the cook time
is an hour 35 prep time is five minutes
sure sure literally sure if you're Aina
my prep time for everything is an hour I
feel like people don't really talk about
how aina's name is like literally the
latter half of a vagina
no they don't like has anyone else
thought of that like yeah obviously
right not me
the bundle of nerves
next they'll be calling it urina
yeah
[Applause]
oh my God you're funny
coming from my favorite comedian thank
you that means so much coming from my
favorite comedian and I am a comedian
because I have a podcast in the comedy
category you are a comedian I think so
you're yeah you're a comedian
cool you're a humor podcaster I'm a
humor podcaster I'm a podcaster with
humor is there a reason you're not going
to the Second Story I know because I was
just soaking up the compliments
okay I just felt like you were Tilly
telling like you were waiting for me to
do something I actually love our Second
Story Jennifer Lawrence said that a Dale
can I keep calling her Adele though
Adele told me not to start in passengers
and I should have listened to her
Jennifer Lawrence revealed in a new
interview with the New York Times that
none other than Adele warned her not to
star in passengers the 2016 romance
space drama co-starring Chris Pratt and
directed by Morton tildum the movie is
one of Jennifer's most notorious
notorious critical bombs with a 30 on
Rotten Tomatoes score is that audience
or critic because one matters 100 gen
cited passengers as one film in her
post-hunger games career where she felt
her fans dismay over her career she was
like quote Oh no you guys are here
because I'm here and I'm here because
you're here wait who decided that this
was a good movie
um she said Adele told me not to do it
she was like I feel like space movies
are the new vampire movies I should have
listened to her that's actually like
really wise for Adele she said after
Hunger Games I was not pumping out the
quality that I should have and
um passengers and films like it led her
to step away from the spotlight quote I
just think everybody had gotten sick of
me I'd gotten sick of me it had just
gotten to a point where I couldn't do
anything right if I walked a red carpet
it was why didn't she run
um I actually don't know remember it
that way we got to that point not in her
movies and that's not how I feel right
but in like her red carpet just tripping
and she was just everywhere was like
very Anne Hathaway yes I was gonna say I
don't think it really got to the level
that Anne Hathaway got to it because I
think she removes herself she's really
self-aware she got right out of it she
got right out of it exactly
um but also another uh bombshell I think
from the same interview was that she has
decided not to play Elizabeth Holmes
like there was a movie being made and
she said Amanda Seyfried did such a good
job like why are we doing it again wow
and so she said she's not doing it
anymore maybe like this passengers thing
has her looking really critically yeah
was nominated for like every award she
was really incredible I watched like a
couple of episodes so
I don't think it's a story that needs to
be told again in the same year and
it was great and the story was told and
there's so many stories out there like
go find another one watch any watch the
whole season of American Greed and there
will be so many movies that you could
make what about that tree farmer who the
woman came in and like totally conned
him out of all of his life savings and
his family's Tree Farm was the woman
named no and like she came with her
daughter and then she had like the
daughter being like the mistress like
it's very Heartbreakers and it was
heartbreaking for me because the the guy
lost his stroll tree farm and now it's
like raised to the ground ah
that's horrible make a movie about that
make a movie about that
um so jayla's just like obviously in her
transparent era and we love that yes
except I will say I saw passengers I
don't know why I saw it in the movies
like I said I wanted to go to the movies
and I didn't hate it it obviously wasn't
great but it was fine you know
passengers is for me I think
um it is the movie where a lot of people
speculated that she was having an affair
with Chris Pratt and that was the one
where they said like for the intimate
scenes they just had a bottle of wine
and went at it right and then like he
was divorced shortly after that so I
think like image wise that also wasn't
great for her that could be part of the
reason why she like regrets the choice
hmm again not none of it is confirmed
but and also I mean her other movies
including Hunger Games like that's huge
in its own way but like Silver Linings
Playbook like
the one with you know
the guy in the glasses
yeah American Hustle American Hustle
thank you really all Oscar you know and
then after that it was like she did a
movie a year and it was Oscar Oscar
Oscar or Oscar yeah but past Winter's
Bone passengers is not that that was her
first movie
yeah no her first movie I know it what I
feel like I've said this before on the
toast it was this movie it was kind of
like Indie um and she wasn't the main
character it was about two people who
fall in love but like live in different
countries and like end up like not being
able to be together because of like the
green card and then they get their green
card and then they end up hating each
other and like he leaves her for a girl
who's Jennifer Lawrence what the [ __ ] is
that movie called like someone
someone knows what I'm talking about I
saw it in theaters it was so [ __ ]
depressing and that was the first time
ever look at this IMDb your favorite
okay favorite also Joy don't forget
don't enjoy did she win anything for Joy
I don't think she was like crazy what
what year is that 2011. okay like right
before Hunger Games yeah but she was
like also not the main character got it
but that was the first time I saw her
and she was like so beautiful yeah I
feel like if she we were talking about
this with Viola Davis like everyone has
a flop era
um no one is gonna have like a perfect
roster I mean look at Tom Hanks okay so
if you have one movie that like you're
embarrassed of and it wasn't even that
bad like you're fine also did you ever
see red Sparrow she plays like a
a Russian ballerina turned spy I feel
like soon she's gonna do
um something in like the comic Universe
like that she's an X-Men oh she is she's
Raven Mystique she's so
um we literally wouldn't know no I know
if Ariana Grande did something in the
comics no if Taylor Swift like was
Superwoman I would have no idea right
and which is crazy crazy
girl anyways don't be so hard on
yourself Jennifer I think passengers is
a fine movie and the fact that like
Chris Pratt is there to shoulder some of
the burden it's not that embarrassing
it's like two good actors who obviously
had chemistry but it's a weird plot sure
yeah no I don't think it's that bad like
that's your flop you're fine yeah
I don't like I didn't feel negatively
towards it when I left watching it I was
like fine it was a movie that was just
like a movie yeah it didn't feel like oh
really because it was literally only two
people now that I think about it oh
that's weird it's about a spaceship
they're going is it room
it's it's a space room space room
because it's a spaceship that's going to
a new planet that's like all set up
gorgeous everything but it takes
hundreds of years to get there so
they're frozen in the spaceship like so
they're sleeping for 100 years but her
his programming is [ __ ] up and he
wakes up early but how miserable he's
alone on the space so he wakes her up
and he woke her up I don't know she
sounds kind of good and so they're like
falling in love and they have the whole
spaceship to themselves and it's really
do they age on the spaceship so they
wind they the whole time they're trying
to get back into it but eventually they
realize they can't and they live their
rest of their lives on the spaceship
they die before it even gets to where
it's going do they have food or anything
yeah everything is tricked out because
it was it's like the Titanic of
spaceship just in case someone wakes up
no and when they boarded there was a bar
you know got it it's so they're good how
interesting it actually sounds like I
kind of want to see it yeah I think I
made it sound really good the thing I
actually really like about Jennifer
Lawrence is she's not like you know a
press girly she doesn't have Instagram
or anything but like if there's
something she wants you to know like
she'll she says it you know what I mean
she's like very like you saw her 73
questions like what's the biggest
misconception about you she's like I
never [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein oh I
didn't see that she's extremely direct
yeah yeah I love that didn't see that
when was that recently she was on this
the September issue right right right so
they did seven or three questions in New
York
and I'm not sure oh yeah she lives here
yeah but it kind of also looked like she
was like outside on the highway I don't
know
um she I forget what the question was
exactly but it was something along the
lines of like what's something people
think about you or like the biggest
misconception she was like that I [ __ ]
Harvey Weinstein wow yeah hmm I should
watch that
are you ready for our next story bye I
am Luke Evans is weighing in on
Hollywood's casting row and insists that
the right person should get the job he
says quote I wouldn't have a career if
gay people only played gay roles
Luke Evans has weighed in on the
argument of whether only gay actors
should play gay roles saying he wouldn't
have a career if that role was applied
across the board the actor who was known
for roles in The Hobbit Beauty and the
Beast and nine perfect strangers oh woof
I forgot about that I never even
finished that show and I have no idea I
started the first episode and once a
full Kidman came out I actually turned
it up I think this 10 episodes and I
watched eight and like and I still never
asked anyone what happened because I
literally don't care
oh my God it was horrible yeah oh I
didn't expect to be taken back right now
I'm so sorry are you triggered I'm
I'm triggered no I just wish I read the
book because I think the book is really
good it's about a wellness Retreat yeah
and you when that movie when the show
came out you were literally like on your
Wellness yeah it started like right when
I got back and people were like don't
read it before the retreat oh it's gonna
like make you like crazy scared of
everything and everyone so I didn't I
was like I'll wait for the show
otherwise I won't like the show if I
read the book didn't like the show
anyway anyways back to Luke Evans he
said Talent should be the top
consideration for casting Luke who is
gay said he has only played gay
characters twice in his career so far
and would hardly have worked if actors
were cast based on their sexual
orientation speaking to the Daily
Telegraph the film star was asked about
his thoughts on the Doctor Who
showrunner Russell T Davies saying only
gay people should play gay Parts he
replied I'm not sure about that gay
people have definitely missed out on gay
roles for sure Russell spoke very
powerfully passionately about this point
I get it and I totally think that things
do need to change but from my
perspective firstly I wouldn't have had
a career if gay people played gay roles
and straight people played straight
roles I'd have played two roles out of
the 30 six projects that I've worked on
or whatever that number is it's like
yeah who's counting uh clearly you he
said it should be that the right person
gets the job talent and ability and a
big bit of luck and timing that should
be the reason why you got a job it
shouldn't have to do with anything else
so I feel like this conversation has
been had for like a few years and at
first like people were like yeah like if
you're gay you should play gay no like
if you're if the role is gay you should
be played by a gay actor um and then
like that kind of spiraled into like all
different other like identities and like
then you know people were getting
canceled for just simply questioning
like well then what's the point of
acting if we're all just playing roles
that are like similar to who we identify
as right and we've had this conversation
even when it comes to a fat person
playing a fabulous or is a skinny person
in a fat suit taking away the
opportunity for someone else and like at
the core of this conversation like I do
agree with the motivation behind like
there aren't you know you're more likely
to get ahead in in Hollywood if you're
skinny and straight like that's just
what it is so I get the motivation for
like wanting to give more opportunities
to gay actors to plus size actors two
transactors I get it but at the core of
this policy you were literally it's the
antithesis of acting right so that's
what I struggle with because like I do
believe like you know there should be
things in place that make it easier for
everyone it really should be like an
equal playing field and it's not but I
don't know if forcing gay actors to play
gay roles straight actors to play
straight roles transactors to play trans
roles fat actors to play flat roles I
think that literally negates the point
of being an actor yes so I don't know
what the right road course to take is to
to make it like an even playing field
for everyone and making sure everyone
gets equal opportunity but I don't think
it's pigeonholing people
to playing roles that they are
that are like so obvious you know what I
mean like because if that was the case
like then what like why couldn't a black
actor play a role that has been played
by a white person you know what I mean
like then it's just like everyone is so
separate it's like
it's like kind of going backwards yeah
you know yeah we were just talking about
that in terms of food yes and different
cultures right and I don't think it has
to be all or nothing I feel like there
are cases where it's extremely clear
like remember a few years ago when they
were saying that there was once a
conversation that like Julia Roberts
should play Harriet Tubman right that's
obviously not right but I do think when
if if we go all in on on this Theory
like eventually you get to a place where
it's like well blonde people should play
blonde people right and redhead should
play redhead no totally and I also think
like when it comes to this conversation
like
it's not equal in the sense that like
for so long there was like this big
brouhaha like if you're gonna play like
a marginite
marginalized character like it should be
a marginalized person but that didn't
apply to every group you know because uh
and I know people are tired of me
hearing talking about this but like when
I found out Rachel Brown's my hand was
not Jewish like I lost my mind like
she's such a good actress I thought she
was Jewish good acting but also it's a
show essentially about Jewish culture so
it's like well if everyone is gonna get
the same treatment then fine but that's
not the case and I I don't know but also
like Rachel brasahan clearly was the
best woman for the role because she's
incredible and I thought she was Jewish
because she's such a good actor right
and maybe this is an interesting like
line to put it at like Mrs maisel is not
a real character I'm not a real person
right so I feel like when it's a
fictional character it doesn't bother me
so much if it's not a Jewish person I I
don't like elements of marvelous Mrs
maisel but it was never because she
wasn't Jewish I felt like there was
other 100 with this show and the way
they portrayed Jewish culture so I feel
like but like with Joan Rivers I was
just gonna say that needs to be played
by a Jews I feel like when it's a real
person if it's something in history
Harriet Tubman right
um I mean but Harriet Tubman is not even
something we can say because you can't
pretend to be black if you're not right
so but I know what you're saying but so
I think when it's a real person it
should be as true to the real story I
think when it's a fictional character
it's okay yeah I need to think more
about and I might not work for
everything like it's different for
everyone because like if there's a movie
a fictional movie with a main character
who's trans like that Jared Leto movie
which I heard he was in kreb Dallas I
think he plays someone who's like a
cross-dresser or something
um
no no it's like a few years old he won
like the Oscar for it like and it was
and he was amazing but the main
character was like it's like a one
sentence yes it's like a once in a
lifetime opportunity for a trans person
to be like the main character in a movie
so then I'm like well maybe so I just I
really feel like it's Case by case yeah
but I think this overarching blanket
statement we put on it well it's like if
you're not gay you can't play it I don't
think that's fair I think Luke Evans is
right like the best person for the role
should take the role yes get the roll
yes so I don't again I'm just like
talking through my thoughts I don't have
like a full like statement on how I feel
yet you know yeah and I think this is a
conversation that a lot of people are
having clearly like Luke Evans is
responding to someone else who has an
opposing position like I think that
everyone is kind of deciding for
themselves yeah and for themselves yeah
also like just think like if that were
the case like who would have played
Gaston because Gaston was as straight as
they come
so true and Josh Gad played Le Foo who
was gay right so it's like the opposite
maybe maybe Josh Gad would have been
Gaston and Luke Evans would have been
lefu but I would say those wouldn't be
the best men for casting no they it was
Beauty and the Beast was a perfectly
cast movie start another list of
perfectly cast movies Beauty and the
Beast Hairspray okay hold on hairspray
is a perfectly cast movie
just movies
Hairspray
Beauty and the Beast I'm sure there's
more but there I sleep over
Jane Lynch I mean she was incredible
incredible even though like that's not
the world I would have pegged her for no
no but that's the thing about Jane Lynch
she's incredibly diverse yeah that is
the thing and she's the hardest working
woman in Hollywood
after you 100 but I don't live in
Hollywood so
are you ready for our next story
Kelsey ballerini will co-host the 2023
CMT Music Awards and carry under what is
set to perform so um the 2023 CMT Awards
should not be confused with this CMA
award yeah no it's very confusing which
are imminent but it should be like next
week or something it's November CMA or
two CMA okay CMT is April 2nd 2023 so
this is a little bit of a long lead time
yeah I appreciate the excitement
um country music fans get excited
because a date has been set for the 2023
CMT Music Awards and a few exciting
announcements have come with it on
Wednesday CMT and CBS announced that the
fan voted awards show will take place on
April 2nd for the first time ever the
show will Air Live From The Moody Center
in Austin Texas Moody's Point that's
where they're doing it from in addition
Kelsey ballerini will return a CMT to
host for her third consecutive year she
revealed during a surprise appearance at
Carrie Underwood's show at the Moody
Center on Wednesday so Kelsey joined
Carrie on stage unexpectedly to present
her with a big belt of and also to
mention that Carrie is the most awarded
CMT Artist ever I feel like I still
think it's so funny and weird how like
in country music like some of the
biggest acts host the award show it's a
drake hosting the Grammys like it's so
weird yeah but she's a really good host
I feel like that's and they all are
great like side hustle it's never been
bad like they all do like a lot of
hosting [ __ ] on the side like Kane Brown
has done it Brad Paisley Carrie
Underwood like
I'm sure it's fun for them because they
all do it like frequently but I just
think it's like such a funny weird
distinction between pop and country yes
you know yeah
um but back to this
I saw the video of
Kelsey ballerini like surprising Carrie
Underwood on stage and like maybe it was
just me but like I felt like Carrie
Underwood was like like not happy to see
Kelsey like she was like giving her
dirty looks and like
I don't know I just like felt weird
Vibes anyone else yeah it was I don't I
wonder if Carrie knew she was coming I
feel like if she didn't it's like a
little Annoying not of Kelsey to do but
of you know the powers that be like in
the middle of a show right no and it's
like we're timing everything like I'm on
like I'm on I feel like Harry had to
have known totally she did look like
surprised and she did look like annoyed
yeah that was like it was a kind of a
weird video
like Kelsey was just like trying so hard
to be like Smiley and happy and like
this is great and Kelsey cariana was
like giving her dirty look that's really
awkward I feel like in country like a
lot of the girls like they stick
together you know they like lift each
other up they're always like
hanging out and I feel like Carrie
Underwood is like not a part of that no
well I think from I think there's like a
young or country females like group chat
and Carrie Underwood wouldn't be in that
no no no but I was talking more about
like the energy about like women in
country like you're always like lifting
each other up living a country women in
country and I just I wouldn't like put
Carrie in that bow well because like
like Carrie and Miranda like they're on
a different level they're on a yacht
somewhere else
but also Carrie and Miranda like I don't
think I've ever seen them like interact
yeah cause they're country Divas they're
country Divas no I'm like I'm like I
need our country divas and I also I love
the group of country women supporting
country women but there are some country
women who like don't need to support and
be supported no but also like maybe
Miranda and I'm just like putting words
in people's mouth I can't stress that
enough maybe like Carrie and Miranda
like like wow it's so nice for you girls
have this now right because of us no and
like we didn't have this right so like
have fun at your little Gino I'm gonna
be on my yacht yeah maybe that's what it
is yeah I think that's what it is I
don't think that they need to be there I
don't think that they should be there I
don't think that they want to be there
but it also gives me like Nashville
Vibes in the sense of like Juliet and
rain and Connie Britton because you know
everyone's like the blonde hair like
Kelsey ballerini's they've been saying
forever she's like the next carry under
the next Carrie Underwood but Carrie
Underwood is like not going anywhere so
maybe it's like a little rain of James
Vibe you know yeah no Carrie's like at
the top of her game and she keeps
getting topper and topper like I mean of
course it would bother anyone to like be
told like the usurper is here right but
it would bother me as a usurper to say
that I'm the next someone it's like no
I'm the me now no I'm the first me no
one has ever gotten huge by being the
next someone yeah no people just draw
that comparisons because it's like
fairly you know blonde hair like sparkly
boots Consulting to both of them I agree
no and and I've been saying this like
all month like Kelsey ballerini's like
out here like doing the best and the
most like her music is so good she does
not stop working
um I missed her tour because she was at
Radio City and I was out at a show in
Long Island but like I heard it was
incredible like Sarah was she's really
she's we saw her last tour the
Heartbreak tour or the the woman where
she performed in front of a big heart
where did we see it I think it was
PlayStation theater I think it was like
in 2018. yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um I really wanted to go to this one but
like she's on her own as the first
Kelsey ballerini she's doing just fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay ready for our
fifth and final Story the final story
Bruno do you want your dinner no
wow Bruno knows the word dinner he does
whenever
um so he knows that we're dinner it's
the only food word he knows so if it's
like breakfast and I want him to know
he's eating I'm like that's funny or if
like he he knows treat too but if I if
he was like running into traffic and I
needed to turn him around
me and our our one is I can't even say
it of course we'll go if I said it you
guys you I've seen it yeah no but Theo
does the same thing yeah of course
because we do
want to eat he doesn't know or want to
treat but it's not even about what we're
saying because sometimes it's the Trope
it's the Trope because sometimes we'll
say it like this wanna eat
oh no oh no my sweet bird wave but
sometimes we'll be like and he'll
literally still get up because he knows
it's the Trope come here Bruno oh my God
that was come here I'm so sorry come
here do we have any t-r-e-a-t's no darn
darn darn well sorry Bryce you'll be
fine I'm sorry Bruno oh you know I have
some in in his leash all right so we'll
get you out we'll get you soon come here
are you ready for our fifth and final
story it's one of our favorite subjects
to talk about here at the toast
ourselves it is okay second favorite but
the lottery yes winning Powerball
numbers drawn the jackpot has grown to
1.5 billion but it's been drawn somebody
got it do they say it would stay it
nobody won the jackpot but some lucky
players won two million and one million
dollar prizes so that means that it goes
up again yeah yeah until and so now it's
at 1.5 billion they drew it for 1.2
billion Lottery players looking to get
rich quick like Claudia ashrae were on
the edge of their seats Wednesday night
as then actually you were in no I ended
up not even getting the tickets and I'm
like so happy nobody won because now
I'll get well maybe someone would have
won if you got the winning numbers were
2 11 22 35 and 60 and the Powerball was
23. we should do a segment on this show
where we announce the Powerball numbers
the Powerball or anyone who missed it
okay give me the number and that way we
can talk about the Powerball we've got
two I feel like I'll be so good at that
next up 11 and
22. coming in 22 35 35 60 and 60. those
are your Powerball six good night New
York
thanks mclartia you're welcome
uh so nobody won yet we're at 1.5
billion
um May the odds be ever in your favor
this is your sign to go out and get a
ticket and by the way um like if a
toaster wins like exclusive interview on
the toast like
don't get a twisted I feel like I saw a
headline this morning It's All Coming
Back to Me Maybe I saw it like in
between snoozes
um a financial advisors warning you not
to if you win it don't take the cash
take even though you should take the
cash always but they're saying because
of inflation it would so dramatically
reduce oh risk of making poor investment
decisions that is true too oh yeah but
and the gulf between cash and annuity
options has become larger because
inflation has prompted a rise in
interest rates which in turn results in
potentially larger investment gains
right with annuities the jackpot cash is
essentially invested and then paid out
to winners over three decades yeah but
what if the Powerball goes broke and
they can't keep paying you no totally
and
um look if I won the lottery I would
definitely call it JG Wentworth because
I have an annuity and I need cash now
call JG Wentworth 877 cash now is that a
regional commercial or national I feel
like
did you know that commercial yeah and
she grew up in California yeah he's a
national King 100 like Gigi Wentworth
like is he single
um so good luck to everyone you should
get a ticket I still I mean don't take
my advice and then like don't blame me
if you like win and take a cash and
spend it all in a month it's not your
advice it's the financial advice no the
financial advisors would say
leave it with the Powerball
no I don't leave money no no it would
eventually be more and yes if the world
were perfect I would say yes but like
what if the Powerball went bankrupt no
and also like at some point like how
much money like Okay so let's say you
cash out and it's 500 million but then
if you had left it in it would have been
600 million like I know it's like 100
million dollars but like you have enough
money for like literally three lifetimes
I'm sure plus like the risk right no I
think you take it all like you say I
want my money now that's what you would
say when you walk into the Powerball
office I said would you like you know an
annuity and you say
I want my money now and they would say
okay do you want the lump sum or do you
want your first payment now like and I
feel it more clear I want my lump sum
now okay thank you ma'am there's no need
to be so demanding or saying the way
that like Powerball is like not so it's
1.5 million dollars and like when you
get rid of like taxes
it's literally 200 million dollars like
it's insane but yeah there's still a ton
of money but it's so nefarious like that
lump sum thing like yeah well I get my
lump sum be the total now like yeah I
want it all now yeah no totally
um so if you get a ticket and you win um
you absolutely have to come on the toast
that's just like kind of a prerequisite
there's so many questions
the thing I feel like we should there
are people who win lotteries every day
not like the billion dollar Powerball
but like we should have a threshold like
if you win more if you've ever won more
than 50 million dollars in the lottery
you should come on the tote there's not
a lot of people like that because I
watch my lottery dream home and most of
the people win Max like two million
dollars but usually it's like a couple
hundred grand right which is awesome
which is amazing and like life-changing
and you can you know pay off your house
and all those things and I feel like we
know what people
would do with that money but like if you
won like
life-changing eight figures you know uh
lifestyle changing money eight figures
great I we would love to hear from you I
agree totally
um well that's our show those were the
stories reading anything good no I
haven't been reading start your book I
didn't I found out my book club is not
on Monday it's next Monday so I have
some time before I have to read your
book looks really good you want to tell
everyone about it it's called woman on
fire and it's something about art I
don't know much about it art Nazis oh
now it's reminded me that you did talk
about it because then I told you it
reminds me of the movie woman in gold
with Helen Mirren and that's where
Robert Kraft got married right
and if you're not interested in reading
the book about it you should watch the
movie it's an amazing movie Ryan
Reynolds is in it everyone loves him
yeah
I guess Helen Mirren plays a Jew ass in
the movie Helen mirror and I I claim her
as a Joe like she's so Jewish and it
really just depends person to person do
I like you I agree like if you're and
even if it's a Jewish person playing a
Jewish person the first like the average
do I hate you do I still hate you 100
stop casting a hundred percent are you
hateable right gotta go do we claim you
nah
so that's awesome
thank you so much listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to
subscribing give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcasting
group podcast can be found at Spotify
iTunes District public radio I hear we
do castbox all the places where we
listen to podcasts find us the morning
just leave a five-star review about our
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an incredib day and we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye redheads will be up
very soon please don't ride on the
redheads